Trascrizione: Giulia Cattadori
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Buonasera.
Che emozione, super amplificato.
Quello che avete appena visto è l’inizio
di una recente opera che ho realizzato
in collaborazione con, come
sempre accade, con tante persone, in
questo caso Unfrainset 721 e Crazy
Pandas ed è sul formato della NFT.
Io però oggi non vi parlo di NFT, seppure
un tema interessantissimo,
assolutamente all’interno di
un sacco di dibattiti
a tratti decisamente controverso.
Quello che mi interessava delle NFT era
più che altro quella dimensione singolare
dimensione spazio temporale che potevo
inserire all'interno della mia pratica.
Diciamo che per cercare di smarcare
l’NFT e togliercelo da davanti subito,
quello che hanno fatto
questi signori, quali signori?
quello che è successo
tramite le NFT, questo formato e la
blockchain è riuscire a trasferire
l’unicità che era propria di un oggetto
di solito di un’opera,
di una scultura, di un quadro
ha un contenuto puramente
digitale totalmente smaterializzato.
Ed è proprio questa smaterializzazione il
punto che mi ha interessato, lo spazio che
questo corpo nel corpo dell'opera non
occupava più e nel binomio indissolubile
spazio-tempo, il tempo che
alterava in qualche modo.
Ed è proprio il tempo il punto
della mia chiacchierata oggi.
Il primo dei punti: ce ne sono due,
l’ultimo alla fine ed è quello più
importante, ovviamente.
Diciamo che quest’opera
s’intitola Forever.
Inserisce il termine in termini di tempo
già dal nome stesso, è il prodotto di
varie cose, di vari elementi,
però ci sono due oggetti-soggetti
principali che vedete.
Da un lato c’è una bottiglia di plastica
che in qualche modo già racconta
diciamo così, un tratto complesso della
nostra situazione contemporanea e chiama
subito alla memoria qualche cosa che ha
a che fare con la sostenibilità,
con l’ecosistema, però
all’interno ospita e contiene la
materia che è fondamentale per la vita,
che è l’acqua per cui già
si muove questa forma
portandosi dietro
un minimo di frizione.
Questa forma rotea in questo balletto,
questa specie
di oroboro costante e si entra dentro
e si trasforma, trascende,
diventa un altro oggetto del mercato del
consumo, un altro contenitore che è una
bottiglia di vetro e a livello, in un
gioco degli elementi, l'elemento che la
caratterizza, in questo caso è il fuoco.
È evidente che l’immaginario collettivo
ci porta subito da un’altra parte.
Ora queste due polarità,
queste due tensioni,
questi due momenti così diversi,
continuano in una danza costante.
Un balletto, appunto, come dicevo prima,
una specie di uroboro a intervallati
uno dentro l'altro, senza mai
concludere uno o l'altro.
Il loro percorso, la bottiglia non viene
bevuta, la Molotov non si distrugge e va
in mille pezzi e contro nessuna parete.
Rimane però questa tensione, la tensione
che un un tempo infinito, ideale quindi
non un tempo reale, può raccontare.
Ora micro, macro, micro, macro,
micro macro.
È un tema, diciamo così, l’interregno tra
un tema gigantesco, talmente grande
che ognuno di noi può affrontarlo
in una maniera differente.
Io ho cercato di inserirlo
all’interno della mia pratica
ho cercato di relazionarmi a questo tema
così interessante, così vasto
inserendolo all’interno del mio mondo.
E allora ho fatto una divisione,
ho iniziato a immaginarlo
quasi come se fossero dei luoghi,
anzi degli spazi.
Allora c’è una dimensione
micro che ha una dimensione
interna, che ha uno spazio e un tempo
tutto suo, singolarissimo, unico, una
dimensione macro, una dimensione esterna
che evidentemente, ha un altro tempo
totalmente diverso, è un altro
spazio totalmente diverso.
L'equilibrio tra questi due elementi,
in qualche modo, forse definisce
l'equilibrio di un individuo,
di un essere umano.
Che cosa è successo al tempo esterno?
Definiamo lo tempo materiale,
quello macro.
Nella mia vita e immagino nella
vita di molti di voi.
Ho registrato l'accelerazione incredibile
di questo tempo esterno.
Questo tempo materiale che ha generato
anche di conseguenza un interesse
incredibile, è un'accelerazione talmente
costante, a tratti addirittura incessante,
da diventare talmente presente da non
essere neanche quasi più percepita da me.
Era una forma di stallo, quasi.
D'altronde se non ci fermiamo, non
la apprezziamo l'accelerazione.
Tanto questa, questa dimensione,
questo momento di grande accelerazione ha
generato una specie di piccolo strappo.
E io parlo della mia esperienza,
ma secondo me
qualcuno qua come me l’ha sentito
un po questo strappo,
questa specie di piccola divergenza
tra quello che succedeva fuori,
la velocità costante e lo sforzo e
anche l’interessante che ci
imponeva e la dimensione interna, la
nostra dimensione personale, privata.
In questa logica,
la tecnologia, se è possibile,
ha accelerato ancora di più un
processo di accelerazione, tecnologia che
rappresenta uno degli esempi maggiori più
alti del genere umano.
È il frutto di passione, emozione,
ricerca, sapere, condivisione del sapere.
Tecnologie che però tante volte e
recentemente sempre di più è stata un
pochino, come dire assorbita nelle logiche
che sono invece delle logiche di
mercato, ma soprattutto del consumo che
questo mercato riesce a generare.
Ora quella crepina
di cui parlavamo prima.
A me personalmente dentro di
me proprio si è aperta.
Io ho dovuto fare un processo di a ritroso
per realizzare questo momento,
quella frattura.
Però quella piccola lacerazione
è diventata ancora più grande.
E tutto, io ricordo con precisione,
la forza e l’energia, lo sbilanciamento
totalmente a favore di questo tempo
esterno e la mia incapacità delle volte
di ritornare in quella dimensione unica e
magica e soprattutto vitale, che è il
nostro spazio, il nostro tempo interiore.
Da lì, in maniera spontanea, è nata
un’urgenza fondamentale ritornare
in contatto con quella dimensione,
trovare il modo.
D'altronde poi, se ci pensate bene,
io ci ho pensato tanto.
Ovviamente perché dovevo venire
a parlarne con voi.
Se ci pensate bene, quella è proprio
la dimensione che ci identifica
come persone che ci dà che ci,
che ci permette di avere poi una presenza
e un corpo all’interno del dibattito
all’interno dell’esistenza materiale
di entrare in contatto con gli altri
in una maniera specifica di raccontare
una differenza che è
la cosa più importante.
Allora questa urgenza a poco a poco si
è materializzata con l'importanza di
coltivare questo luogo, di coltivare
questo, quest'altro spazio, quest'altro
tempo, che non per forza deve andare al
ritmo di quello esterno che spesso non
riesce a tenere al ritmo di questa
accelerazione costante.
Ora è qui, entra in gioco l'altro
tema fondamentale.
E la cosa forse che ha più senso che vi
racconti qua, essendo io un artista.
La pratica artistica, la pratica artistica
nel mio caso rappresentato.
Evidentemente quella, quella forma, quella
quel vettore che mi ha permesso di
rientrare in contatto con
quella dimensione.
Uno strumento efficacissimo è proprio una
e ha proprio delle capacità che altre
cose non hanno proprio perché si può
permettere di essere tutto il contrario
di tutto si infila tipo una specie di e
non solo tipo una specie di levetta
piccolina nella trama dell’ordito del
tessuto spazio temporale ne genera
un altro totalmente diverso, che si ciba
di altri ritmi magari
anche più veloci
di quello esterno.
Ma non è il problema.
Più veloce, più lento, è differente.
E questa dimensione, questa dimensione che
crea l'arte, diventa proprio il luogo
che, se lentamente noi pratichiamo,
è un luogo che ci aiuta. Ora, quando
io parlo di pratica artistica, non parlo
solo della pratica artistica di chi la fa
cioè io che vivo, di questo e di
questa energia da sempre, ma di chi
vive questa esperienza, di chi vive
l’arte, quello che genera questo processo,
quello che ha generato in me, che mi
auguro possa generare in tutti  nella
migliore delle ipotesi, una rinnovata
consapevolezza di questo spazio,
soprattutto nell’innovata consapevolezza
di questa immensa dimensione che
abbiamo dentro che evidentemente ci
permette di entrare in contatto
con noi stessi in una forma diversa.
Ci toglie quella sensazione che spesso
io ho avuto di inadeguatezza,
l'incapacità di tenere quel ritmo esterno
così interessante, così carico ma così
tanto tiranno.
No, molte volte ora.
Una delle cose più magiche che scopriamo
riabitando, usando i tempi dell’arte,
vivendo i tempi dell’arte e riabitando
questi luoghi come se fossero dei luoghi.
È proprio la capacità di
avere una visione.
Tanto si dice sempre la
visione dell'artista.
La visione dell’artista non è nient’altro
se non la capacità, la voglia e la
costanza di abitare questo luogo, abitare
questa dimensione, che ha un tempo uno
spazio diverso e che si pone proprio
differentemente con i problemi che delle
volte può generare questa differenza, ma
con l'immensa capacità proprio creativa.
Ora riuscire ad avere una visione e
cambiare la visione di noi stessi e
riuscire quindi, in ultima istanza,
a proiettare questa visione fuori.
E quindi riuscire a ritornare a parlare
in punta di piedi di un tema come il
futuro, che è evidentemente caratterizzato
da un paradigma di dramma.
Ahimè, a ragion veduta sotto
ogni punto di vista
e da un livello di criticità assoluto.
Ce lo stiamo raccontando tutti
perché è tangibile.
Ora questa possibilità è
data proprio dall'arte.
Non è l'unico strumento, non è l'unico
vettore che ci porta in contatto con
questa dimensione interna che ci permette
di ricostruire questa visione di noi
stessi inseriti nel mondo.
Però è sicuramente molto efficace e ed è
quello di cui io posso parlarvi perché
l’ho vissuto direttamente nella mia vita.
Questa criticità e la criticità che
vediamo in questo momento è trasversale,
assoluta e tocca tutti i punti.
Però in qualche modo è anche la
motivazione che ci deve
spingere adesso per cercare
di compiere questo salto.
D'altronde l'individuo, l'essere umano,
almeno non so voi, ma io raramente ho
fatto degli scatti evolutivi in una
condizione di relax totale, di completa
tranquillità.
Ci mettiamo sempre in un angolo sempre più
fetente per cercare di fare dei salti.
Ora io credo che questo angolo sia
sufficientemente opprimente in questo
momento e io vi consiglio proprio di
iniziare a praticare l'arte come luogo,
come come abitudine con i suoi tempi,
con i suoi spazi, la
sua differenza dal flusso.
E mi riferisco all'arte, non al mercato
dell'arte, i suoi flussi, le sue, le sue
capacità di raccontare storie diverse.
E questa cosa produrrà, come ha prodotto
in me un cambiamento, una trasformazione,
un'evoluzione, un'espansione di questo
spazio che da piccolo ambiente che ci
dimenticavamo di frequentare, diventa
quasi una fetta di territorio, quasi
una parte intera del paesaggio che produce
e produce una visione diversa,
una visione di noi.
E soprattutto ci mette nella condizione,
in ultima istanza, di iniziare
a produrre una visione di un mondo nuovo
e quindi magari alla fine, anche di
riuscire a trasformarlo un po’.
Grazie. (Applausi)